so at the end of the thing we do I think
at the end of the thing we do a
unhelpful advise people email us and we
answer questions all those real nails or
the clip ons or whatever but they're not
press-ons they're acrylic so they're not
real he's scared of nails are you really
yeah yeah like long nails why those just
[ __ ] so freaked the [ __ ] out of me
what's the fear death strike you know
what when I see this in porn and then
one fingering yeah I'll never forget
that smear yes I always imagine it's
probably gonna feel that way I totally
know what like my soul sisters have yeah
have you ever done this photo on
Instagram where you say oh but I did it
like that on purpose because it looks so
stupid when they do this homes but I up
I purposely make it like this that time
but you did it for a joke yes not like
really check out my nails or was not an
elbow thing where like I'm gonna make it
a joke by a lot of people nobody sees it
don't lie double a double eye or
unhelpful advice with Barbie
kalila at G hey tiger what's up sup sup
that's your real last name no it's gone
handle we'll wait Bart Kuan yeah your
real last name because if marriage is
quiet yeah might you want my legal yeah
Daniel so where did I come from
that's my middle name are you Giovanna
yes Giovanna Kwon on a recent episode
Bobby talked about addiction how it's
something you gotta accept and try to
control not sure if it's the same but I
now know and have come to realize that I
have a really bad problem with
masturbation it affects my schoolwork
exercise things I enjoy and always
leaves me feeling like I'm disgusting
for what I did it isn't so much the act
as it is that I'm using it to escape
real life for some reason when I'm close
to finishing my mind fills with things I
don't exactly want to see at the moment
people I idolize things I enjoy doing
people's faces I don't get why this
happens and out why I can't stop what
can I do to try to overcome this love
you guys be clear when those faces pop
in his mind when he's about to come yeah
when he's a finish
close to finishing my mind fills with
things I
exactly want to see at the moment so why
is he addicted to something he doesn't
want to see I don't know it sounds like
it's two different things
yeah I'm confusing time Joe Biden that's
a true yeah brain is supposed to go
blank for like a split second we don't
know why Joe what I have no idea he
winks so I don't get why this happens
and why I can't stop so maybe just
doesn't know why this happens how old is
he no age mm-hmm
if he's 40 it's weird if he's 17 mmm
yeah you drink off til you die if you're
17 you're alive he's going to school
right he says yes cool yeah so he's
young but if you're like you know if
you're working if you're like a banker
and you're not going to work because
you're jerking off and yeah that's a
problem yeah yeah oh so he's fine
give me another yeah I I don't I don't
know what to tell him because I'm
talking about right now dude I just
understand what his mind okay let's just
let's just assume he has amassed a
chronic masturbation problem well it's a
disease okay
addiction only if it gets in the way of
like responsibilities right yeah I think
that it is you know you know that's why
they have sex anonymous like sex people
are addicted to coming and and obsessing
and the chase and the whole thing it
alters your feelings so if it's a
disease you gotta get checked you gotta
get help for it I think the part that
throws me off is like like when he's
saying he's thinking of other things I
just feel like his mind is like
obviously preoccupied with something
else cuz I mean that's happened to me
where I'm like I'm like in the middle of
it and I'm just like wait why am i
thinking about these things right now
he's like the last thing I want to think
about yeah yeah then like you want to
focus more on like the porn so that
you're not thinking right so that's why
for me it felt like it was two separate
things but he's saying that he uses it
as a way to escape real life so that in
itself is a problem but I'm also
noticing so one of those things were
like I think that when I'm about to [ __ ]
I try to think of him I try to come I
want to think about other things I don't
come right away
like no I think about like look because
I don't want to come I happen to be on
top he does have these moments oh baby
no baby no why is he dude why she's
trying to remove me off his yeah you've
never done that lift up
Pelayo I feel like wiggling nobody
didn't want to come yet so he's coming
in three seconds okay yeah do it [ __ ] it
I don't like there's no shame in coming
the other day we shake yeah I like
spring or cheese I don't like when you
do that he doesn't spread it in a way
that's like yeah you want to crack bass
hold on okay like that
[Music]
yeah it could not go far enough for her
stretch it
[Music]